let's say we want to have a system where we
group or put words under categories
and we want to do this automatically. We don't want to do this manually.
So for example, let's say you want to create a
social media application and you want to
you know, let's think about words that can mean very different
things in different contexts.
So the name of a company like apple, right?
Apple could be a fruit. It can be a company.
How we know what it means? It depends on the text surrounding it.
Or topics or or books if you want to or a
web pages you want to associate web
pages by different topics. So this webpage is about Finance.
This webpage is about sports this web
pages about
football whatever
How would we?
How would we go about classify Google everything we have?
is a vector of numbers like so
okay.
Let me show you what an example.
Let's say we have we have these three words and they represented as vectors
of distributions.
Cosine similarity is about this.
I'll show you how we calculus in a moment.
But it is the angle.
created by these two vectors
the smaller the angle the closer they are
to each other.
They have a closer meaning they're associated with each other enough. Obviously the
father. They're apart the less similar. They are this is
a very good example. This is a very nice picture so you
can see the cosine similarity of
drone
or the code the code that the angle of drone and helicopter and
Rocket are
Closer to each other relative to you know
Goose eagle and B.
So if you would take the cosine similarity of drone and
ego you'd have what
we call it an up.
Is that an obtuse is that an obtuse angle? But it's a
it's not even it's even less than 45 degrees.
Anyway, you'll get a bigger cosine symbolarity anyway, but
I'm trying to say is the larger the angle the less similar
they are. So for example B and Rocket, you know.
They're very dissimilar.
So what I want to show you is how to produce such a thing.